[Musique]
retrouvez mon fils où j'ai pas de
nouvelles de lui depuis plusieurs
semaines de balard comme dans mon dieu
quel bel arbre ben e
elle est la bête non mais là vous
écrivez blard ben on faisait rien
corrigé label arbre c'est noté j'ai
l'impression que personne n'avait jamais
rien chez vous et fabrice est en train
de faire un avis de recherche nous
sommes à la recherche de ce jeune homme
ça vous dit quelque chose
mais c'est pas du tout d'elliot ça tue
ses cuisses un leurre mais bon vous
foutez de moi humble armes
c'est peut-être pour ça que personne n'a
plus oui c'est aussi parce qu'il va dire
au téléphone c'est pas eu quelqu'un qui
ressemblait pas à ça vous êtes un vrai
fardeau respaillès